[Musique]
les experts disent que peu importe la
forme sous laquelle on consomme
c'est le choix du café et les
certifications qu'il reçoit qui peuvent
nous aider à faire une différence
en face à rennes est la plus connue
foirest et plus performant ce qui est
moins exigeant pour pour mouler les
torréfacteurs donc la pression sur les
prix est moins demandée
puis le cahier des charges est beaucoup
moins important c'est ce que ça fait
c'est pour des compagnies comme les des
gros joueurs de ce monde c'est beaucoup
plus apprécié travailler avec ça parce
que ça coûte moins cher cette
certification ne garantit aucun prix aux
producteurs
c'est pour les coopératives c'est des
coups c'est un coup pour aller chercher
la certification c'est un coup pour
faire les audi c'est un couple des
équipes donc eux qui vont leur garantir
naxn certaines niches de marché mais ça
leur garantit rien au niveau du cou
certaines vont travailler davantage sur
le plan social d'autres plus sur le plan
environnemental rain forest a peut-être
une grande force au niveau du côté
environnemental
mais il ya des bons systèmes en place
pour s'assurer que ce soit fait dans les
règles de l'art les droits humains si on
parle de faire un prix plancher plus
exigeantes et plus rigoureuse la
certification fairtrade offre une
protection financière importante aux
producteurs en les mettant à l'abri de
la spéculation
cela leur permet d'investir dans de
nouvelles méthodes de culture plus
durable et d'améliorer leur qualité de
vie peu de gens le savent mais
l'entreprise aussi et pour la neuvième
année consécutive le plus de monde
malgré cela il faut être vigilants quant
à ce jour il n'y a qu'une partie des
produits que rick qui affiche la
certification fairtrade la certification
la plus solide à mon avis et biologiques
selon nos experts
l'idéal est d'acheter un café certifiés
fairtrade et biologiques mais cela se
traduit par un coût plus élevé pour le
consommateur
quand vous avez ces deux là vous êtes
assuré qu' il va avoir un volet
environnemental et social qui va être
pris en compte
quand on voit des fermiers qui
travaillent qui innovent comme ceux qui
réussissent à vendre 4
plus élevé honnêtement moi ça me dérange
pas qu'il me levant un prix 300 % plus
cher mais je suis capable de ventre ou à
100 % plus cher moi aussi parce que je
capable d'expliquer pourquoi les
différents certes un petit geste dans
notre vie de tous les jours peuvent
aussi avoir un impact réel comme acheter
des capsules compostables ou opter pour
des capsules réutilisables
nous ce qu'on dit a acheté le plus
possible en vrac
de plus certains endroits à cordes des
rabais si vous utilisez vos propres
contenants lorsque vous achetez du café
en vrac
idéalement on va acheter son café dans
un petit facteur de notre coin avec
quiconque est capable d'échanger puis
qu'il nous dit ben moi j'ai acheté ce
qu'a fait lors de telles coopérative
tchéquie et certifiés fairtrade
organique donc on est capable d'avoir un
peu plus d'informations et on peut
toujours demander justement les gascons
ici demander conseil sur leur
certification
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce que
ça implique souvent ils connaissent bien
leur café mais leurs produits donc on
peut demander le qu'est ce que nous
conseille puis de nous parler de leurs
différentes sur des cafés philo il
provient les torréfacteurs de plus en
plus on
dans ce milieu-là du café vraiment des
influenceurs très très fort justement
les cafés prix hors de la maison dans
des contenants à usage unique sont une
source importante de déchets au canada
chaque année c'est 1,6 milliard de ces
contenants qui se retrouvent à la
poubelle
la plupart sont même pas recyclables
soit les gens croient que le temps c'est
tragique ces risques là mais
malheureusement une petite couche de
plastique à l'intérieur qui fait qu'on
peut pas séparer du carton donc c'est
directement à la poubelle
même les couverts sont souvent jetables
non recyclables au coeur aux broderies
favreau certaines mesures ont été prises
pour diminuer l'empreinte écologique
on était très conscient que l'industrie
serait jamais un industries vertes mais
nous on s'est dit on va se fixer des
petits objectifs qui de semaine en
semaine on va les voir évoluer
la première chose qu'on a faite c'est au
niveau des divers on étudie les verts
compostables
une des choses qu'on a fait c'est
d'acheter des produits de café qui sont
plus proches du canada donc on va
essayer d'éliminer tous les cafés d'asie
on veut aussi délimiter les cafés et
d'afrique
mais au final pour avoir moins d'impact
il faut moins consommer on s'entend que
le café considérée comme une commodité
intelligente elle consomme souvent par
habitude comme ça mais rarement un peu
comme une bière comme un verre à
dégustation
ben ouais je pense que ton choisi son
produit on revient à des rites mais qui
sont un peu plus loin on va les choisir
son produit on va le préparer soi même
puis ont voulu plus l'apprécient après
que l'on boit son café à partir de
capsules que l'on prépare avec une
cafetière filtre ou expresso il n'y a
pas de façon de faire qui ne laisse pas
de trace sur l'environnement à moins 2
j'imagine si on est convaincu que le
café de mahler gros de la nappe il ya
une solution facile ce serait depuis
hambourg oui mais ça fonctionne très
prenant
[Musique]